[Music]
how's it going man my name's beautifu
welcome back to the kid I know you or
your fans here in handy at we hate you
this map does not make smart Jess oh
okay this plot thickens
guys we should do something about pips I
agree he's so [ __ ] lame I will
unsubscribe pretty soon as soon as I'm
done playing this game you [ __ ] okay
just possum shut up you don't even know
who you're talking about
I love this all right what's up lady
where's the funny I'm outta here you
guys [ __ ] suck ah what is it Stefani
isanother doing here I didn't see that
one all right so we're going somewhere
else now wha
whoa what's going on here
ah no no no oh [ __ ] whoa this game is
really [ __ ] creepy let's go oh [ __ ]
hello no it's wrong number
stop calling [ __ ] out at all Jenny said
whoa whoa what the [ __ ] is that
what in the hell not but what are you
doing up here
that's get speak [ __ ] let me respond Oh
more plants
what is this [ __ ] what I don't speak
Japanese seven women think I speak
Japanese all right that was interesting
whoa cut out there I can't come back
fine I think tasket that means like save
me or something
Japanese skills all right sorry about
that
they said coach you to you that means
like come and get me or something or
coming Japanese skills sorry about that
Oh
ah well then if you call me one more
time I will slap hear that but exactly
how I planned it
my boss just stopped hurting shut up
woman go down my sensors a bit too close
I'm sorry about that
all right I think we're dead
oh I hid in the closet she saved me that
little gap that's everyone at me at a
kalasa
all right I was a creepy little doll
hello creepy little doll hi did I good
yeah I know it's you again don't kill me
I gotta follow you to catch an arrow in
the was that what the hell was that I
don't trust it oh it's a toilet
I trust you toilet okay what's in here
chair is making love that's [ __ ]
gross I got a sensor that bloody door
that's very healthy for your stamina
that creepy card on it
yes thing then oh oh oh no I can't use
my flashlight
oh nice out man please just [ __ ] just
for good on time see
this is pretty [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mukai Simon no bueno bought a pittypat
boss head of Sethos I was trying to say
no good for my health I know he's
Spanish try it
Hey she went in there good kind of gotta
yeah this is a lot better than last time
it's not a picture of the corridor I
just went through that's nice [ __ ]
hell man
it's like Hello shut up let's yeah what
a night
actually way better than that what
what's up Danny oh yeah that's weird
fetish dad wait dad what data we did it
we did it we did unlocked a new one bit
chest what's up what Oh wasn't too bad
Oh too bad this is a couple of jumps
guess nothing to worry about where's the
funny tired of this [ __ ]
YHA you will never get Stefania unless
you make out with me now I'm gonna make
out with you it's not gonna happen I'm
going out here what do you want let's
say it's a robbing door you stupid [ __ ]
fine go here now that O'Shea
what Matt yeah I don't know about you
but I wouldn't go inside of buildings
that someone is crying in that's just
actually that's how I got to an MA
Oh ba ba
okay it's gonna be fine if I come back
Oh what the [ __ ] is going on
oh it's just a toy hi I could ride this
in their name and it would be awesome
okay
Hey just talking about you okay my poor
little heart every night
oh [ __ ] there's someone underneath
all right I need to find those things
well that guy's gone now whoa okay all
right now we can proceed there's like
charms to keep people away or something
nice what with that oh we've been here
we've totally been here I don't like
this place if I was a parent last time
but we're gonna go off there this time
yeah we'll go over here that gosh not
this again what sorry I don't speak is
that high five
I guess it was like high-five surprise
that's okay not everyone is a big fan of
- I have a I'm a high pirate I'm not
gonna go in that period
oh it's up there oh it was here I'll I'm
not going there
woman what do you want step calling me
don't jump-scare me here again please
good what's that thing
what's a funny girl pooja loudly hell
better speak up
I have no idea what I'm doing
oh that's no good okay good thing I'm
here oh geez wow this place
[Music]
we're fine we're fine
everything is happy and fine
this is laughing now huh ah ha ha
ah that is
let me describe that
Oh No the end god damn job stress man my
little heart
I wasn't that affected huh cool I'm not
gonna guarantee that I finished this one
but we could do one more this plot
thickens
my heart is broken because Stefano has
left me I no longer want to live anymore
Jace's guys woman I really sorry but I
really gotta move this sensor I don't
even know where we're supposed to go
all right we're going out here whoa whoa
what you doing sir Oh Rose I'm gonna
have to call my mom and because I want
to end this episode yeah doctor not good
favorite did you enjoy subscribe today
[Music]
whoa Paranormal Activity crown Robin
always wears you got
[Music]